I just feel that I'm a person that has
something to say and instead of saying
it and using words says it by just
putting some paint on the surface
my name is Nahal Ronnie and I'm a street
artist from Balu the reason I paint
portraits or figures that kind of show
our culture is very simple when I
started painting all over the city I
used to have to remove photos of
politicians and political logos and
election posters these politicians who
are necessarily good at their job occupy
most of the urban landscape and this is
where I actually wanted to replace them
with something more positive that the
citizens have a route that the presence
of these people is really optional there
is a very complicated question of
identity when it comes to what does it
mean to be Lebanese and this is another
reason why I paint these faces they
represent the stories of Lebanon Beirut
and the Arab world in general a mural
can make a war not only a war but maybe
something that creates a relationship of
people with with an element in this tree
and I think it kind of spreads
positivity and changes the perspective
of people from their everyday life I
really appreciate that the people that
compared me to Banksy I really
appreciate that his work and I think
it's smart it's witty and he has a lot
of credit when it comes to the global
street art movement
I don't paint just for the sake of
painting or for the sake of capitalizing
on a certain event I just paint when I
feel that I have something constructive
to say
you